[Music]  a very different tone in Las Vegas last  night lots of Tears love and emotion as  Celine Dion returned to the stage for  the first time since Sunday's tragedy I  never start to show like this standing  in front of the curtain  but tonight is very different choking  back tears an emotional Celine reassured  her fans there was a reason the show  must go on  [Music]  on Sunday will lost too many beautiful  innocent souls but tonight we are going  to let these families know that we are  supporting them so I want you to know  that the proceeds for tonight's show are  being donated to the victims families on  your behalf the heartfelt show it's  Caesars United over 4,000 fans and 100%  of the proceeds will go to the Vegas  victims and she's an open book when it  comes to her personal life - in fact  she's told me that she feels that her  fans deserve to know so she didn't keep  it a secret that she was blessed with  her three kids with help of IVF  [Music]  you